how do everybody welcome back to let's
play cry of fear okay I've been trying
to figure out this puzzle I don't think
I have enough information or something I
don't even know what the cardinal
direction Oh what's this
so I went oh this controls the lion the
lion move Center I found that the pads
for the other ones I pressed them I was
thinking that up here that would be kind
of a way out maybe more information
don't look like darn it okay looks like
I'm gonna have to figure this puzzle
okay the lion moves side by side is
right the equestrian move west is their
way can I figure out like I don't know
the cardinal directions I got no son
we've got to be a way to find out the
Cardinal
what's up here okay I'm up here
I can't get up here I can't jump over
that really a wimp this guy is I go in
the water
no all right the bird of prey flew
higher I'm guessing the directional pads
I'm just going to go and guess that
they're north west south like it is
North who hire some go too nuts north
the owl I think the line is stalking
that as its prey I don't know the horse
went West present I dare you
went west ok is it already west like it
was the horse is West the line stalks
side-by-side its prey
the four-legged carnivore sneaks side by
the king of all the birds flew higher
than the owl ah so the AL goes south
maybe could be and let me just dumb it
if it's side-by-side I'm gonna put the
line west and I'm gonna try the owl Sal
it seems as good as any other guys
it seems weird that a line would be
hunting an owl I don't know
let's go come on y'all I'm guessing it's
south bingo
who's the man I did not look anything up
oh yeah
Booya for me Oh gold star on my board
yeah ah
I know it's wasting two bullets but I'm
gonna reload it sorry I just don't want
to be caught that's cool
who puts a puzzle like that in the
middle of a park key got a gate key no
get uh oh yeah give me some okay god I
just got to get the urn maybe I could
dump the gate key ah ah what to do what
uh
let me just I'm just I'm just doing this
just to see what it's like because I
want to see that's a good number bullet
does it have a zoom in yeah it does but
I don't see why I need it okay
hunting rifle maybe is it worth it I
don't know
I would definitely trade it for the
assault rifle but for a hunting rifle
I'm not sure I can justify it so hunting
rifle gets dropped for now sorry
everyone if you like the under grapple
but I'm gonna stick with this we'll
stick with the pistol plus I got more
bullets
and I can hold the pistol and the phone
at the same time so it's better for
close-quarters so that's that's enough
reasons wait did that that's a moot
point now I'm going to go get them
yeah go go get it don't worry about
dropping things later yeah Oh what did
you just trip on the stairs buddy Simon
I think your name is looser you are for
this guy all right cool
all right moot point now where you give
me the hunting run I'm lady Oh back oh
all right don't trip over any stairs
good job all right
oh my god what am i doing wonder how
many people got stuck on that secret art
puzzle Wow I got a sniper rifle holy
crap what's with that Oh nailed you
Davis what it's a bed you're just
floating up I was a bed
what what uh I don't know
oh I only have like five bullets in this
thing I thought there were more bullets
in here Oh better go back I saw
something else why did that deserve a
level pin maybe it's not level
transition maybe season
Basia I'll feel a bit Oh nailed it
Oh heads up huh I hear another one I'll
see ya coming let me get a better shot
at you Oh what oh what Oh boom Oh miss
come on sorry I make no claims that I'm
the best sniper the world I'm not I'm
not the best you look like some close
quarter combat
I wonder if this game is giving me
choices because it seems like no matter
what route I pick it generally sends me
in the direction that I progress so I'm
more curious actually giving you a
choice maybe there are different endings
I don't know Oh doll scared
come on you die you stay down and you
die all right enough of that
what phone phone answer the phone hello
hello I can't hear you who is this
I'll just you get my number here can you
help me what the [ __ ] is going on in
this town your what your up on the roof
uh-huh I can't hear what you're saying
come on man even I feel oh hello are you
still there
nope alright that's interesting okay
something about heart okay I see
movement
ah I see fast moving oh you all thumb
you Oh what oh boy I will bang it up it
did that's right
stay down why why I see you I see all of
you Oh what is all Oh what did ever oh
no me Julia I obey oh well hang on wait
one second I just need a moment
okay here I need a moment all right
there we go
ah guy here's a there we okay I see you
another one through the bushes there
what was that oh yeah
stay right there good there Tara dare i
getcha getcha I got you I got you didn't
haha but let's do somebody
ahh you killed your friend I knew about
that
alright I'm switching to the Bucktown oh
wait I got at home
did I drop the baton oh no I wasn't
watching my health ah all the ones in my
health I damn it
Erna darn it oh yeah the baton gut drag
dad maybe whatever alright fine
I gotta go through the whole phone call
thing again oh but pain in the butt oh
this is the wrong way
actually I'm gonna cut it here guys and
by the time I get back he'll be past all
those guys so thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next markiplier Oh